sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh plan
show so today is going to be a really exciting
show we're trying to understand what is going
on with the markets and what we can expect from
bitcoin throughout the rest of 2022 so i have an
amazing guest to delve into all of this but before
we dive in this particular month is sponsored
by um the cryptocurrency exchange bitmex so a
huge shout out to bit max because without them we
won't be able to bring you such valuable content
as of may the 17th they're actually launching a
brand new spot exchange to easily and instantly
buy and sell your crypto so to celebrate they're
giving away 1 million dollars in crypto to sport
traders over the next few months and this is
actually one of the biggest giveaways in crypto
right now so if you are um eager to enter then i'm
gonna leave some information with a link for you
in the description so it's gonna be really
exciting there's a huge range of different
assets that you can actually trade on there so
the information is all in the description and
a huge thank you to bitmex because without them
like i said wouldn't be able to bring you such
exciting content so let's get into this joining
me today is lynn alden from lynn order investment
strategy to help us try and make some sense of the
markets lynn how are you good thanks for having me
yeah it's really great to have you i've been
following your content for a while and you
seem to be getting this spot on you were early um
with tara predicting what was going to happen so
i'm really excited to get your perspective on the
markets right now but before we get into all of
this you have a strong background in aviation so
i'm really interested to understand how you went
from the aviation industry into finance where did
that come into things yeah it's a good question
my background is electrical engineering and
specifically i worked in the aviation industry
uh i started out as an engineer and then i worked
me up in into engineering management and running
the finances of that facility um and going back
prior to that i had you know i had a long-term
kind of interest in finance and investing um
as well as science and math and technology
and so i kind of pursued the engineering field as
my initial profession while investing on the side
and then at some point i decided to switch out
of that and focus on investing in you know public
research public writing full-time and you do the
traditional side of things you know you talk about
markets like securities commodities um and then
you also get involved in crypto digital assets so
this is really interesting because they're
obviously very different so do you think that
digital assets like bitcoin are the future or in
10 to 15 years do you think that you're going to
continue to stay diversified with traditional
markets well i mean i think it they basically
are a new platform for things that already exist
so in many ways for example bitcoin is a commodity
right it's classified for most tax purposes like
a commodity you know it doesn't pass the howie
test so it's not a security it's not an equity uh
so the best analogy we have for it is a digital
commodity and then you have things like stable
coins that are digital fiat they're just digitally
native fiat it's a new medium for fiat currencies
and they have a variety of other platforms that in
many ways look like look like equities right for
example they have a network they have a platform
uh and then they invite people to use their
platform uh in various ways and then people
can judge what is the total adjustable market
of that platform what does long-term outlook of
that platform look like uh and so you know i think
that that basically this is being integrated into
you know markets as they currently are and we'll
see what kind of technologies come out of this
so in about 10 to 15 years you don't think they're
going to be considered alternative markets it's
just going to be part and parcel of how people
trade essentially is that what you're saying
well i think bitcoin will be here to stay probably
in 10 to 15 years i think that has a long runway
of growth ahead of it before you know unless it
runs into some sort of tail risk so that's number
one i do think that stable coins basically that
money is going to flow over blockchain rails more
so i'm bullish on the proliferation of stable
coins for example i think that's a better medium
than we'd be using in the past um and then
you know we'll find out what the total just
market is for distributed compute basically
you know smart contracts federated networks
uh you know we'll see if they can be used to bring
down settlement times things like that uh that's
still a very highly competitive industry and a lot
of that's been kind of based on i think artificial
incentives um and so when the dust settles we'll
see you know what is the actual kind of underlying
utility for some of those technologies yeah
absolutely things are still playing out um as
they always say we are still early so it's going
to take some time to sort of see what's going to
be there in the next next 10 to 15 years but what
we know is not necessarily going to be there is
something which you predicted uh this week so i've
never seen anything quite like this um with luna
tanking to zero you predicted exactly this i think
about two weeks ago on the first of may you said
if the lunar price declines ust would lose its peg
and the lfg um would have to sell as bitcoin to
stabilize ust so how did you come to this analysis
do you have to have some kind of engineering
finance background like you to be able to have
this depth of knowledge how did you land there
uh so that was mostly from analyzing it as though
i would have analyzed an emerging market and they
were kind of using similar overall economics and
so for example if you look at emerging market
central bank uh you know they issue liabilities
which is their emerging market currency
and then they have they they hold other assets
such as treasuries or gold that they can use to
defend that um and you know if they start to
run low on those reserves you have to really
get concerned about that currency and
so what essentially an algorithmic
stablecoin is it's kind of like an emerging
market central bank that runs on autopilot
they're not really prone to stability there they
kind of always have these inherent weaknesses
and you know terror tried to shore up their
weaknesses by buying bitcoin in a similar way
that emerging market would buy gold but my concern
was that you know in a in a risk-off environment
which is what we're in now uh you know most of
the crypto space tends to suffer and when that
happens to lunacoin luna's like a total equity
value compared to their uh ust value uh that
can eventually erode the value of their equity
and result a death spiral which is what we saw
so you predicted this perfectly well my question
is why were we able to get into the situation
where people have lost their life savings i don't
understand how people weren't able to i don't
know speak loud enough about this those running
you know doc one why wasn't he able to spot the
weaknesses here how did this happen i think there
are two things uh number one is that it's hard you
know it's so i kind of outlined what would happen
the question was i didn't know when was going
to happen right so i don't know if it's going to
happen in may i don't know if it's going to happen
in june i didn't know if they'd be able to salvage
this get more capital injection ahead of time and
push it back another year right so it's hard to
say when it's going to fail so that's number one
number two is you know i think a lot of people in
the space they have a low incentive to be critical
and a high incentive to kind of promote things
uh and especially with an algorithmic stablecoin
it's really based on confidence uh and so
it's always confidence confidence confidence
uh and i just think not a lot not enough people
were critical now there were plenty of people
besides me uh and even some of those helped inform
uh the research i did right i didn't just come up
without a no write i researched different things
that people were saying i did my own analysis
um and so there were plenty of people
out there i i just think that you know
too few people listened to them too many people
were wrapped up in the gains they were having
yeah a lot of hopium as they say um they sold i
think it was confirmed today or yesterday don't
remember they they sold around 80 000 bitcoin
what's the problem with using bit bitcoin
as collateral for other blockchain networks
because i know a lot of people think that that's
sort of some of the reasons why the market's
tanking although bitcoin seems to be stabilizing
at around 30 000 what what are the issues with
using bitcoin's collateral for other networks
so i think it's it's not necessarily using
bitcoin as collateral that's the problem i mean
it you know in some ways it's ideal collateral
it's still because it's a young asset it's still
volatile though so it's less it's less uh
you know it's more volatile than treasuries
or gold or something like that so you have
to put up with volatile collateral which is
not ideal uh but i think the bigger issue
is that just by adding bitcoin to something
doesn't fix that thing if that thing is inherently
unstable it doesn't matter if you have bitcoin
reserves because your thing is unstable right
and so you know maybe if they had more they
could have you know they could have prolonged it
they could have had it this whole death spiral
will be a lot slower than it was it would have
been less spectacular um but basically you can't
fix a broken system by adding bitcoin to it
um and so you know if a company wants to add
bitcoin to their reserves as a percentage of their
long-term holdings i think that can make sense
um but if you are inherently an unstable
protocol uh bitcoin doesn't fix that i'm
interested given the amount of research and your
understanding um on this digital asset space
what would you say you're most bullish on which
would withstand the test of time then so i the two
areas that i'm bullish on in the crypto space are
bitcoin and stable coins um and you know really
with bitcoin what we're seeing is the test of this
new asset we're seeing how hard it is we're seeing
if we can stand community disagreements softworks
you know all the different challenges there so far
it's been able to withstand that and so i think
that's a long term then it's going to withstand
the test of time uh most likely and then the other
one would be that there is a strong global demand
for money for low volatility money which is stable
coins basically uh and the way fiat currency works
is that they they try to control volatility by
devaluing gradually over time right so a dollar
loses value year after year year but in most
circumstances it doesn't explosively lose value
over say a two-month period and there's you
know the people around the world where you know
they're living in double-digit inflation uh they
have restrictive monetary regimes and you know
for example in argentina or lebanon if you
had dollars in the bank let's say you made the
decision you don't want to hold the local currency
you want to hold dollars uh they just took the
dollars they can just take them and convert them
to local currency and then you get devalued anyway
and so ironically for them for people you
know they'd rather trust you know a foreign
custodian uh they could hold dollars to them on
the blockchain and take any sort of risks that
might come with you know the the quality of their
collateral things like that versus storing dollars
in their own banking system uh and so i think the
combination of bitcoin long-term and stable coins
kind of you know intermediate term uh i think both
those things are real use cases above and beyond
speculation uh that i think are going to persist
for quite a while in this industry people keep
looking at bitcoin as this like you said you
know something which is it's new but it's sort of
withstanding the test of time it's a hedge
against whatever's happening um but inflation
is just hit a 40-year high um the fed is you know
increasing interest rates to try to tackle this so
do you think that bitcoin is going to be able to
withstand this supposed recession which is coming
so i think it will withstand that but there is
significant price risk over the next 12 months
uh and if you look back historically
you know we can even put the question
of recession aside and just look at economic
acceleration or deceleration because not all
decelerations result in outright recession
and so over the past decade for example you
can measure it in the purchasing managers index
which is a basically measure of economic activity
and it looks kind of like a sine wave
that goes up and down every three years
and some of those downturns result in recessions
and other ones result in say near recessions they
almost cause recession but there's some sort of
monetary policy pivot or fiscal stimulus that kind
of reflates it from there uh and so historically
bitcoin has generally done very good in rising
pmi environments so economic acceleration
liquidity is flowing most most risk assets do
well and something with a lot of volatility
like bitcoin generally does even better
then of course many of the altcoins you know they
skyrocket and then when you have the declining
pmi environment uh all coins get killed bitcoin
suffers uh stocks in general especially riskier
ones uh overvalued ones tend to suffer whereas
things like cash defensive value stocks gold
those sort of assets generally hold up better
and right now we're kind of firmly in the middle
of a declining pmi environment uh now that
doesn't mean that bitcoin can't you know like
in the in the prior declining pmi environment it
managed to bottom before pmi bottom it doesn't
just follow this this perfectly uh so i think
we've already seen quite a lot of the washout
whether or not we get a lower low i still
think is anyone's guess what makes this
one so challenging is that because inflation is
high the fed is is trying their best to tighten
monetary policy into a weakening environment
they're appropriately trying to reduce demand
and basically cause a near recession and i i
think that's not going to go well for them i think
they're going to have to reverse at some point
but until you get that reversal i think we are
in rather risky territories or especially if i was
trading any sort of leverage i'd be super careful
uh and then even unlevered people have to make
sure that they have the right amount of exposure
for whatever volatility they can afford so i would
never recommend someone put 100 of the portfolio
in bitcoin and things like that i just think you
know whatever allocation you want to it based
on your education on the asset your conviction
uh what you think is going to be worth in five
10 years you can have that allocation and i think
you have to be willing to withstand a lot of price
turbulence over the next 12 months or at least
until we see some sort of reversal from these
current conditions which is economic deceleration
combined with monetary tightening which is
you know pretty much anything other
than cash and defensive value things
are are going to have rough time there they say
that bitcoin is this uncorrelated asset i mean
it's obviously not given everything you've just
said but do you think we'll get to a point where
it's going to be uncorrelated and we're not going
to have to deal with everything that you mentioned
so historically it's been moderately
uncorrelated compared to stocks
um it's still generally risk on liquidity play uh
and in the past few years the correlation went up
quite a bit i think there's a couple reasons for
that one is that the macro situation was a bigger
common variable between assets so we had the
biggest ever uh injection of liquidity combined
with the biggest ever removal of liquidity and so
vast majority of assets went up and down together
and only kind of specific things like energy
start kind of breaking out of that correlation
uh and so the other factor would be that bitcoin
got big enough that it's now like an institutional
asset and so you have hedge funds trading it
you have a lot of professional money trading it
and so the venn diagram of who owns bitcoin
versus who owns the nasdaq came together uh
quite a bit there's still there's environments
where i think that could decouple one would be
if you see a reversal of fed tightening so you
have more liquid in the market but say you still
have that combined with uh inflationary pressures
on company margins that could be an environment
where stocks you know they might not do that well
whereas you know commodities including gold and
bitcoin could do pretty well because they're
benefiting from liquidity without having to
worry about margin pressure they don't have
employees they don't have margins they're
they're just you know these scarce assets uh
so that could certainly result in a decoupling
another one would be that you know even though
the the two types of holders have kind of come
together they're still not completely the same
it's not the same people all on bitcoin and nasdaq
and so for example a lot of people are dollar cost
averaging in a bitcoin and they're not buying the
nasdaq and eventually you can dry up all the
liquidity basically exhaust all the sellers
and then get a reversal i think that's you're
most likely to see that when you have more
liquid in the market and when you have a rising
pmi environment so just going back a sec to this
looming recession which is supposedly coming what
what does this mean for the the everyday person
people are always looking for the best way
to hedge themselves against this recession
against inflation and we've kind of been looking
at bitcoin as as sort of this answer don't worry
about the stock market just pick bitcoin don't
worry about property just pick bitcoin so where
does the average person go from here when
they know that this recession is coming so
to take a step back i think we can describe it
we're in an economic decelerating environment
that might or may not go into a full recession i
i think on the current track we are likely headed
towards one but i would i would just you know
caution against saying you know a recession is
sure i think what we can say for sure in the data
currently is that we're in a decelerating economic
environment so that's that's number one number
two you know talk about the average person that
can vary tremendously based on what country you're
in right i mean someone in turkey has a different
currency situation to deal with than someone in
canada for example right and so right now the
dollar is at the heart of the global fentanyl
system so when the fed's tightening you know
basically the reason why when the economy goes
down and the fed tightens the reason why dollars
you know pretty much go up compared to almost
everything else is because that's the that's
the unit that debt is denominated in uh and you're
basically tightening everyone's debts relative to
their assets uh and so everything that's basically
denominated in dollars uh you know struggles uh
and so in that type of environment if you were
in the united states or other developed countries
holding a larger normal cash position can help
you get through that kind of turbulence and then
you can deploy it when you see some sort of pivot
you can get into whatever risk assets you prefer
whereas if you are if you're in a periphery market
if you're in a market that's suffering currency
problems whether it's argentina or turkey and
things like that you know those hard assets are
still working better for you than owning your
local currency uh it doesn't mean every single
week or every single month but if you look at a
long-term chart of say bitcoin priced in turkish
lira uh you know there's no there's no doubt that
it's a good inflation hedge uh same thing for for
gold or same thing if you hold dollars stable
coins things like that so i think the way that
people can interact with this depends on where
they are in the world what their liabilities
are denominated in and and what they're kind of
experiencing in their local markets um so i think
that basically the general trend is that when
you have this kind of risk off uh you know fed
tightening economic decelerating environment you
generally want to be more defensive and that can
mean different things for different people in the
world and then we have that kind of rising pmi fed
loosening type of environment that's when you can
consider taking on more risk and you know another
way to phrase this is that right now we have a
lot of scarcity in things that we want especially
energy energy is scarce and then because that's
the master resource that affects food scarcity
uh and all these other things and the fed can't
print more oil they can print more ships and ports
they can't print more wheat all they can try to
do is try to reduce the demand for those things
that that's that's the way that they can try
to deal with inflation but reducing demand is
basically synonymous with a recession that's what
a that's what a recession is basically reduction
economic activity uh and so in their minds they're
trying to do a just a small one right you know
just trying to take the edge off demand without
causing an outright recession historically the
odds of doing that are very low right so if you
it's like you know it's like being a little bit
pregnant right the fed has a bad track record
of being a little bit pregnant either they they
feel recession or they don't uh and at least more
often than not and so they're kind of on the track
now they're trying to curtail demand and so that
you know that challenges people in different ways
inflation's a challenge for people and then also
when the fed is purposely trying to reduce demand
that's also challenging for people so i think
right now it's kind of you want to buckle down you
want to make sure you have access to the supplies
you need and you want to be defensive whatever
that means for your personal situation why do you
think we've gotten into this sort of mess i mean i
know we've seen endless amounts of money printing
over the last two years we have you know anonymous
accounts on twitter been tweeting don't print
money that's bad like how can these you know
anonymous accounts on twitter with probably no
financial background say don't print money that's
bad and then the fed prints money and we end up
in this situation so is this done on purpose is
this out of um lack of intelligence i don't know
why we in such dire straits i i think the seeds
of this go back decades i think that's the hard
part it's kind of like this big shift there's no
there's no single person responsible for
it it's the accumulation of moderately bad
decisions over decades until it becomes a
severely bad situation uh and so basically
every time we have a downturn right so decades
ago if you have a downturn uh you know you could
just let it play out let the bad leverage go away
let it play out uh they chose not to do that they
chose to inflate the next bubble um and basically
you know get convinced people to take out even
more debt and the problem is you eventually
blow such a big bubble that you can never
retract it you know basically that basically
would crash the even the government bond market
if it were to contract and so they're pretty much
the only way out there is to inflate it away they
have to hold interest below the inflation rate
and you you can't kind of deleverage enough debt
nominally so you have to basically increase the
denominator which is currency units until you
quote unquote fix the problem and of course that's
a very uncomfortable situation for most market
participants and i think that's the stage of the
cycle we're in although there's there can be kind
of you know intermediate term pushbacks right so
right now where they're kind of they don't want
to admit that's what they're doing so okay we're
going to tighten we're going to tighten policy
and i think what's going to happen is the
economy is going to weaken enough that they're
going to have to stop tightening and then you know
inflation is still high and they have to pivot and
then they're kind of out of excuses so i think
that this the problem now is the accumulation
of moderately bad decisions and then you have
other things layering on top of that like the
commodity cycle right there's there's there's
periods where you know commodity prices are high
everybody comes in and you know they drill
new wells they find new copper deposits they
they put all that capex in until they have
too much supply and then you get a you know
decade long bad prices no no new capital wants to
come in until you burn off all that excess supply
uh and that's kind of what we're now we we just
had a uh you know more than a 10-year period of
reducing commodity prices outright deflationary
commodity prices in most cases uh and that era i
think is behind us i think we've already used
up a lot of the excess supply that we've had
uh and now we're kind of entering this another
period of scarcity where until we get a lot of
new commodity and infrastructure supply online
we're gonna have problems uh in terms of
having disinflationary growth so we're either
going to have economic contract contractions or
we're going to have very inflationary types
of growth uh because it's the combination
of the currency being a problem and under
investment in hard assets and you mentioned that
depending on which country you're in your
situation is is is unique to you that you
know you have different liabilities um which is
interesting because today it was announced that
um i think it was 44 heads of states are
heading to el salvador to discuss bitcoin
um el salvador seems to be clearly very much
underwater with that bitcoin investment so i
want to get your take on how smart you think that
their move is so i think their decision to include
bitcoin as legal tender smart i think they've
gotten a lot of tourism and investment out of it
um the problem is that those types of
decisions don't come freely right and
so the biggest risk for them is that foreign
creditors don't want to buy their bonds anymore
uh and so their costs of financing are very very
high um and so i think that's the biggest issue
challenging them right that basically the current
kind of system is built to try to have it so the
countries can't leave the system right and so if
you try to leave the system you know you better be
prepared to deal with the consequences and so
i think that's what they're going through now
um so you know bitcoin can't just instantly
fix a lot of the issues that el salvador has
related to crime related to all you know all the
challenges that historically face the country
um and so when you combine that with you know
the imf and other entities kind of pushing back
on you you know that's a challenge and so in any
sort of declining pmi environment when the fed's
tightening basically what they're doing is they're
breaking all the countries that have that have
kind of done their own thing and we'll see which
ones can get through it i i still open questions
about how successful el salvador is going to be
in navigating this um and i think that remains to
be seen i think there's very little downside you
know say outside of what the foreign creditors
are going to do there's very little downside in
saying you know we accept this other currency
as for as legal tenure in addition to the
one we already were right so they've not
made dollars non-legal tender they still are
and if anything the data shows i mean you know
the vast majority of economic activity is still
in dollars um and so you know i don't think that
the direct implications of using bitcoin have
been a problem for the country i think it's the
international creditor reaction to that decision
why do you think they've had such a bad reaction
well partially because they like the status quo
so if a country tries to leave that status quo
uh that's you know that's not good in their eyes
they want to punish them another thing i think is
that large like managers of large pools of capital
are you know they consider this risky it's outside
of the bounds of things that they're familiar
with and they say you know what i just don't
want to own el salvador bonds that's an easy
you know if i have a portfolio of bonds from
50 developing countries and this one did
something that i understand and it's it's
one percent of my portfolio it's easy for me
to be you know what it's i'm just going to
take that money out and i'm going to put it into
another country that i understand and so i think
the combination of just a lot of creditors that
just said i don't really want to have exposure
and so that comes down we'll see if they can get
alternative financing and we'll see to what extent
that this can pay off in the long term even though
the actual decision of having bitcoin legal tender
has had neutral to positive uh implications
as far as at least as far as i can see yeah
no i don't agree with you i mean i i haven't
yet been to el salvador but i'm excited to go
um for tourism reasons um so yeah i imagine
it's had a huge um it's brought a huge amount of
new new people in which is really exciting um but
okay so back to the markets just for a second so
given billions of dollars has been wiped off the
market very quickly um where do you think we are
right now rao power and willy woo for example
talk about this four year cycle being over
so it's not really driven by the bitcoin harvey
anymore so i'd be really interested to know your
thoughts on that um and sort of where you see us
going like you know from after the next 12 months
to maybe 18 to 2 years 18 months or two years i
think it's investors want to focus on one cycle it
would be the u.s purchasing manager's index cycle
so that that pmi cycle that already referenced
and that's roughly a three year cycle there's
no rule that says it has to be three years
it just historically has been about three years uh
that's kind of the cycle of investment decisions
um and things like that and so i think if
you follow the pmi cycle over time uh that
can give you a general idea of what's going
to happen with risk on versus risk off assets
now that that applies as measured in dollars
right so if you're in a country that's having a
spiraling inflation problem uh you could probably
ignore that and just focus on you want to own hard
assets you don't own your local currency in large
amounts um so you know mostly they're referring to
investors that would denominate their you know
their unit of exchange in dollars um so i would
i would say that we're still in this kind of risk
off environment it doesn't mean we're necessarily
going to get lower lows i have no idea okay
but it generally means that excess risk taking
is probably not where a lot of capital is going
to flow to uh and so you want to look for either
a rising pmi environment or some sort of federal
reserve monetary policy pivot and in that kind
of rising liquidity cycle is where i think
bitcoin would have its next bull run which i
i think at the current time you point out
to 2023 uh sometime in that time frame but
again these cycles there's no hard focus on
them and bitcoin is not bottom and top you
know precisely with the cycle even though it is
closely aligned historically with those cycles
the interesting thing is every metric um on
the bitcoin network is looking pretty healthy
right now the hash rate is at an all-time high um
bitcoin is coming off of exchanges at record highs
i think i read today that um the amount of uh
wallets holding um one whole bitcoin has just hit
record highs user adoption is going up quickly so
in your opinion other than you know this inflation
and everything that we've spoken about what do you
think is holding the price down uh so certainly
one of the factors was what happened with tara and
that was one of the concerns i wrote about ahead
of time which is that if they have to force sell
tens of thousands of bitcoins into the market um
you know that's in an already weak market that's
not great for price and so we saw looking at
exchange data for example is that you know the
record you know coins were coming off exchanges
then you had this big injection of coins back onto
exchanges most likely associated uh with the the
tara luna you know uh defense uh and then since
then it's come off a little bit you know there's
some dip buyers that probably bought in and bought
some cheap sats uh but it's still higher than it
was before uh the luna event um and so i think
that they basically there's tens of thousands of
coins that have to find a new home so there's
kind of you know and then there's people that
are shocked by the price they have we can selling
strong hands buying the dip and i think you have
to have that rotation until you basically exhaust
the sellers um and the buyers are still happy
and so that's kind of what happens in this in this
risk off type of environment another thing is that
you know now all the coins are moving on on chain
right a lot of it's just happening within exchange
ledgers it's also happening in futures markets uh
and so basically there's very few large fast money
pools of capital that are like you know what i
want to buy bitcoin right now right that's not
that's not what we're seeing they're basically i
want to be risk off right now until i have better
clarity on what's going to happen with liquidity
what's going to happen with the economy uh and
so because it's that risk-off environment the
marginal buyer is not really showing up there's
not a lot of outside capital flowing into space
and so you have a difference between what say the
you know the hodlers are doing right so
they're they're showing very strong adoption
uh we've seen a number of people that say we're
in the luna system and then they say you know
what i'm a bitcoin maxi now you know so yeah you
have some rotation there but then you also just
have large pools of capital that are like you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna let the dust settle
and see what's happening with macro before i put
in new capital so basically obviously overall
demand is is relatively weak at the current time
even though there's pockets of obviously very
um you know strong demand yeah you make a funny
point the best way to make a bitcoin maxi is to
have weeks like this i think there's a lot
of bitcoin maxies that have been converted
um but what do you think about bitcoin
versus bitcoin derivatives for example
everyone is pushing for the spot etf which
is good for mass adoption but is it better
to hold the actual bitcoin um or bitcoin
derivatives that can obviously be manipulated
so there are different pools of capital that have
different requirements so i think if you're in a
position where you can i think it's better to own
the underlying bitcoin you know that's kind of the
part of the reason the asset is desirable is
because you can hold it without counterparty risk
right you can hold it you can hold your own wallet
you can have multi-signature solutions uh so i
think that's ideal when possible but there's some
types of monies that is 401k money uh you have it
with an advisor you have it in fidelity whatever
the case may be you have in your brokerage
and maybe you want bitcoin exposure there uh
and you don't want it maybe you don't want to
have to worry about maybe maybe you're fine with
counterparty risk you'd rather trust fidelity
than yourself right and i think there are plenty
of people that maybe want to be in that position
or they want to split the difference they want
to say look i have my own stack but i also want
to have additional exposure that maybe is in my
brokerage account and so i think that there's
different types of products for different pools
of capital um there's also you know say a pension
or other you know kind of large entity like that
insurance company you know their charter might
you know restrict them to buying securities
right that they they might not put all in the
underlying property and so they want a rapper
around it someone to manage it on their behalf
and it could be grayscale could be you know one
of these other types of entities and so i think
basically we have to be aware that there are
different pools of capital that have different
goals with what they're trying to do with it and
different appreciation of counterparty risks or
even preferring having a counterparty and so i
think you're going to see that show up you know
across the board i think the more products that
are available the better i think there should be
a bitcoin etf because a lot of people have had to
buy interior products due to a lack of a bitcoin
etf and so ironically it's not investor protection
it's if anything it is it's funneling investors
into weaker types of investments you know they're
either buying something that is not necessarily
keeping up with the price of bitcoin it might
be futures based it might have it's it might not
trade with net asset value it might be an entity
that takes on leverage basically people have been
forced into those things if they want bitcoin
in their normal brokerage account so i think
over time you know the more products available
the more can be normalized uh in terms of having
a small slice in your 401k or small slice
in your insurance holdings things like that
when do you think we'll see a small etf you know
so i don't have regulatory clarity on that uh i
think i i would say probably the next couple years
we already have bitcoin etfs the question is when
we have one in the united states right and so
yes yeah yeah kind of i think shame the united
states has been behind on this compared to other
countries um so i you know i would not be shocked
if weeks from now you know we have a bitcoin etf
like we have a announcement of a bitcoin etf but
i also wouldn't be shocked if we're sitting here
a year and a half from now and we still don't have
one i think there's basically a small number
of people that have to decide that there can
be one now and so whatever would convince those
people it seems to be that the because we see so
much casino-like behavior on the exchanges that
they that that seems to be a factor in terms of
not having a bitcoin etf which i don't think that
necessarily makes sense but it might be a piece of
leverage that regulators have over the exchanges
so i you know i don't really have a strong
conviction on when we'll have a bitcoin etf but
then i think in the long run i think we'll have
one what's your take on regulation um janet yellen
obviously was saying how the market needs to be
regulated better after um everything that happened
with terror um we obviously don't the us obviously
doesn't have the sport etf yet so it's really
the us is very much behind um so how do you think
regulation is going to play out for the u.s do
you think that it's going to actually be able to
remain at the forefront of innovation when
it comes to the digital asset space so i
think i think the problem is that they want to in
their view protect consumers without suppressing
innovation and one of the challenges there
is that we right now because the technologies
progressed faster than regulators know what to
do with we kind of have two markets right so
normally if you if you have a something that
passes the howie test basically your security
then there's various restrictions you have
if you want to sell that to the public
you have to have certain disclosures and
things like that um whereas in the digital
asset space someone can make something that
for all accounts is a security and then they
can just sell to people uh and so you know
someone from say a very libertarian background
says that's fine but the problem there is and
you have two different types of markets so you
know some people might say everything should be
you should sell whatever you want to the consumer
other people might say no we need restrictions
but few people would argue that there should be
basically like inconsistent regulations where if
you're if you're you know in this category you
can't sell the public but if you're in this other
category you can sell the public and so i think
over time we're going to see more unification
between securities laws and traditional assets
and securities laws and digital assets i think
basically some more of those tests will be applied
to some of those projects and so for example it's
already the case that most of them they can't
you know raise capital from you know the the broad
uh you know american public right now we could see
more restrictions on what exchanges can sell to
the public right i mean a lot of exchanges were
funneling investors into you know mean coins
right at the top of their their part of the cycle
you know it's basically whatever's got momentum
they advertise that they get a lot of people in
and those people get wrecked um and then you know
we see just a lot of exchanges we're selling luna
and then later said that oh we knew that project
was doing fulfilled well why did you sell it to
the public then or why did you know so i think
i think that there's going to be a little bit
more tightening around what exchanges yeah
can make it easy for the public to access
and i don't think that really affects bitcoin
per se but i think that affects some of the worst
uh areas of the altcoin space and then there's
other i think there's more problematic concerns
like making it harder to custody your own funds
um so i i would certainly be against those types
of regulations i think people should have
the right to self-custody their own funds
but i think that's something we're seeing pop up
in the european union uh you see it pop up from
some lawmakers we'll see what can actually get
made into law well that's interesting because i
i saw that within the eu they were talking about
um i think it was you have to screenshot your
wallet address or something like that if you're
using a non-custodial wallet before you send it
i don't understand how that could be
implemented so how on earth could you implement
self like i don't know regulation around self
custody i can't i can't understand that i think
it's gonna be a very big challenge and that's
actually even that goes back to what nakamoto's
innovation was so prior to bitcoin if you want to
send money long distances you needed to go through
a central intermediary a bank basically um and
so if you wanted to if you wanted to do capital
controls or sanctions or restrict where money can
flow the government only had to focus on financial
institutions which is really easy to do uh what
this did is it opened up peer-to-peer transactions
across the world and so if you want to enforce
those types of laws you now have to enforce it on
the consumer layer which is orders of magnitude
harder to do because you say in america you're
focusing on 330 million people rather than a few
thousand banks right and so i think that that is
in the long run rather untenable um now one of the
ways you can do it is draconian restrictions where
you say okay we can't really enforce it too much
but if we catch you uh the penalties are severe
and that's actually what they did when they banned
gold i mean in the united states you couldn't own
gold it was illegal to own gold for like four
decades from the 1930s uh up to the beginning
of 1970s and the penalty was up to 10 years in
prison now the number of people that actually
were charged with any of that was low they
didn't go door to door and get everyone's gold
it was really just you know something that they
could not enforce then instead they enforced
through draconian penalties so we'll see if that's
the route that they try to take but essentially
the whole point of this entire field the whole
innovation here the the foundation for what
makes this space interesting uh especially bitcoin
and stable coins is that they basically unlocked
global peer-to-peer payments and that's
kind of a pandora's box that i think
you know i think different entities around the
world are going to struggle with and i think it's
obviously a bigger problem for more authoritarian
types of places and it's less of a problem for
places where you actually want to live and they
actually have a functioning you know economy
so that brings you into my last topic um cbdc's
because i know that you're like you said you're
bullish on stable coins um but how do you think
cbdc's will be adopted versus stable coins do you
think we'll have both or do you think or do you
think one could essentially replace the other in
terms of orderless payments no volatility and so
on i think that depends on the jurisdiction right
and so a country like china pursued the cbdc route
over the stablecoin route one is that they got a
big head start i mean they started studying that
in like 2014 uh and after years of research and
development they they've introduced uh you know
their version of the cbdc they also have very few
kind of checks and balances on their government
uh they're obviously uh prone to surveillance
and control so that's kind of right up their
alley whereas if you look at the united states
uh you know our officials generally did not
research this very early on um and and so
they're now they're kind of in catch-up mode
and you know in these types of environments
generally public private partnerships tend to
be what's used right so the federal government
will often use contractors for example instead
of making all of our own military equipment
we'll have lockheed martin make it we'll have
boeing make it uh and so i think in in the united
states and some of these other similar types of
countries you're more likely to see stable coins
regulated stable coins be used as essentially
that mechanism uh and so that regulator is still
sort of that out so i i don't have super high
conviction on what what this is going to look like
but i do think that over time um probably some
degree of outside partnerships would be used so
for example the united states can pardon a circle
and say okay that this this is a quote-unquote
bank quality stable coin you can use it for these
purposes whereas this other one is not right and
so i think that's kind of the route that we're
probably going to see in in parts of the western
world lynn it's been so fascinating hearing a
perspective on all of this given the state of the
world and the market right now so i really
appreciate you coming on um do you have any last
thoughts um about you know what's going on right
now people who might be potentially concerned
because they're very much underwater with their
investments and what are your last thoughts
i think this the final thought is to make sure
you understand what you own make sure you have
an assessment of a long-term utility of what it
is that you own uh and and stick to things you
understand because i think this is still you know
whether or not we've seen the bottom you know this
is obviously that this was a uh a big crashing
moment associated with the terror collapse uh
so you know whether or not was the bottom or not
i think things that don't have long-term utility
still have more to lose and then even things that
are high quality can be temporarily dragged down
by deleveraging in associated assets and so
i think it's a it's a risk-off environment
and you want to be careful with your leverage and
with your exposures and to make sure that you own
you own the things that you think have a good five
to ten year time horizon ahead of them in terms
of where this industry is going where can people
follow your work uh so i'm at lynnlawton.com and
i'm on twitter at lenon contact guys please go
follow lin um just amazing value that predicted
everything that was going to happen and with the
tara luna situation so that was really fascinating
lynn thank you so much for coming on it's
been such a pleasure learning from you
thanks for having me guys thanks so
much for tuning in don't forget to
hit the subscribe button and we'll see
you all next week malaya high or pancho